president biden's trying to control what
you're allowed to see on social media
the white house boasting about how it's
teaming up with the big tech
platforms like facebook to flag quote
problematic posts about covid19
and has administration staffers working
to police content online
press secretary jensocki admitting it
yesterday
we are in regular touch with these
social media platforms we've increased
disinformation research and tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts
for facebook uh that spread this
information best words and despite the
backlash and concerns it could lead to a
crackdown on speech
sake doubling down during a clash with
our very own peter ducey
for how long has the administration been
spying
on people's facebook profiles looking
for vaccine
misinformation well that was quite a
loaded and inaccurate question
um which i would refute well peter first
of all
as you know we're we're in a regular
touch with with a range of media outlets
as as let me finish as we are
as we are in regular touch with social
concern though media think for a lot of
people on facebook is that now this is
big brother
watching you they're more concerned
about that than people dying across the
country because of a
pandemic where misinformation is
traveling on social media platforms
and joe biden had this very strong
reaction
what's your message to platforms like
facebook
[Music]
they're killing people i mean it really
they'll look the only pandemic we have
is among the unvaccinated
and that's and they're killing people
all right so jessica
if you're a government official
you can crack down on free speech and
just say hey i'm saving lives
saving lives we're going to take away
your first amendment
saving lives i don't really see how this
is cracking down on the first amendment
because
everything is people nuked off facebook
no well they're not actually so the
study that gensake cited
was publicly available was published
actually in may it's covered by a range
of outlets that said that there were 12
main accounts that were spreading 65
of the disinformation about covet 19. we
can all google i did google it
that's for us to see facebook you when
you post on facebook you do
i don't have an account but if i did i
would post and it would be public and
there could be people in the government
there could be people
people in private organizations like
social media companies that have a
responsibility
to keep people as safe as possible and
covet disinformation
does get people killed doesn't matter
that the white house should be in charge
of labeling what's disinformation
because
the white house joe biden the democratic
party has a horrible track record
when it comes to what disinformation is
i'm not sure that they have that much of
a track record they've only been in for
a few months i mean i said the democrats
too lab leak
open borders oh okay either way laptop
i'm sending a memo russian hoax
let hoax all of that was disinformation
let me just put a hypothetical out and
then greg can answer
craig so let's just say president here
right
we weren't getting anywhere let's say
president trump okay
a couple years ago colluded with
facebook
to crack down on people posting about
the russia hoax
and he said you know what cnn's posting
about the russia hoax it's
disinformation
it's tearing the country apart let's
nuke them what do you think the media
would have said though
uh they've gone crazy and that's
actually a really good analogy
i i interrupted it i said it doesn't
matter none of this
matters once the government is involved
with
a a corp a corporation that's a
violation of the first amendment
that's what's happening it doesn't
matter i mean it doesn't matter if you
believe it's misinformation
it doesn't matter because it's forbidden
every opinion could be misinformation by
your definition that's what the first
amendment is
coming out and saying your opinion i
don't trust this government
and i i do trust you jessica but i don't
trust most democrats in defining what
misinformation is to to jesse's point
i mean imagine the people look at it
from our perspective imagine the people
who spent decades calling us stupid
rubes
and racists are now in charge of
controlling the spread of information by
using the word
misinformation any sane person would say
hell no but we don't even have to say
hell no
we can say we're totally wrong it
doesn't matter this is a violation of
the first amendment
if you you can use the misinformation uh
against any let's say republican
conservative argument a defense of law
enforcement well you want blacks to die
your defense of capitalism you want the
poor to die right a defensive school
choice you want teachers to die
anything could be based on the fact that
these people are going to die so we can
control
the information that's why you have to
stop it now
it's they're they're going to use this
argument they're killing people
to control you and there'll be times
when the information comes out and it's
wrong and it'll be wrong on the left and
it'll be wrong on the right that doesn't
matter
the collusion is what matters here's
what i think happened shannon
the white house really screwed up the
johnson johnson situation you saw when
they came out
and they spread doubt about j and j
vaccination rates plummeted
never recovered right and so now he
doesn't meet his july 4th goal for
vaccinations
and he's just saying facebook it's your
fault and all you people all you
right-wingers it's your fault
and we're going to get rid of you well
do remember just a couple of weeks after
president biden was inaugurated there
was this piece in the new york times and
people laughed it off or whatever but
they had
they talked to experts and they said we
need a reality czar and what we're going
to do
a full federal government response where
across agencies these people all meet
they'll look for disinformation they'll
shoot it down it'll go through the
reality czar who then
will then meet with the heads of big
tech so and a lot of people at the time
are like that sounds sort of crazy
well then when this stuff comes up
people are like well no baby that's
actually what they're doing and
you know it gives rise and it gives um
win to the sales really from former
president trump his
lawsuit against all these tech companies
when he says they are acting as
government actors so if it looks like
there is coordinated
activity between the government and
between big tech it only helps his
argument right of course
so the white house pressuring monopolies
to take out political speech they
disagree with
right and that's exactly the point that
you were making about the collusion so
the legal argument essentially is that
the government has deputized
these social media platforms so allowing
it to serve as an
arm of the government and therefore it's
state-sanctioned censorship and why it's
so dangerous
is not only the facts get censored
whether or not they're true or not
but also the public response to it so
it's twofold
and it's like to your point that the
common carriers that the government has
granted special
status to special favors well the law
then sees them as quasi-governmental
agencies they are in a distinct category
they're not this private company
justice clarence thomas pointed it out
he said twitter has made clear the right
to cut off speech lies most powerfully
in the hands of private digital
platforms and then he went on to say i'm
paraphrasing
that where it gets so so dirty and messy
is when it's a first amendment issue
because the government has been
intertwined with them now and he
essentially said at the time the
question hasn't been raised
but i think jen sake's statements in
conjunction with the former president's
lawsuit means that the time is now
and given all of this the courts will
not rule in their favor
i'm going to give you the last word
because i did rudely interrupt you
jessica did someone get near
[Laughter]
um this is obviously not the first
administration to have a meeting with
mark zuckerberg or with jack dorsey
right this has happened under republican
and democratic administrations and
i would love to see proof that the list
of problematic posts that jen saki or
whoever
sent over to them are actually ones that
got taken down and they do work with
governments
and ngos and officials all over the
world
to make sure that they're keeping the
platforms as safe as possible and that
means to take down videos that
terrorists are posting like that's one
of the main
okay we're done well it's not a
terrorist to say that you don't like the
vaccine that's not terrorism but
okay i should never have given you the
last word
um one more one more you want to say one
more thing
you're making me feel bad jessica the
faces you know as you say it's good to
see democrats finding a flag
that they like no
that's fighting words so much for
following hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else